wir müssen reden und zwar weil dieser
Weltklimagipfel jetzt in die Endphase
geht man kann schon fast sagen es gibt
schon eine vorzeitige Bilanz und ich
glaube das ist hier ein großer Flop das
wird nichts weil es muss jetzt Butter
bei die Fische es ist 11 Uhr alle müssen
die Karten auf dem Tisch legen und das
läuft hier nicht viele Länder kriegen
das nicht hin und wir kommen nicht aus
den fossilen raus Gregor du bist
wissenschaftsmoderator bei Nano du bist
ein kopveteran come on das ist doch
alles hier ich sag's mal ganz drastisch
Bullshit ja ich bin aber auch Optimist
ich würde sagen todgesagte lebenlänger
mal ganz ehrlich die wissen alle worum
es geht die IPCC Berichte sind so klar
wie klosbrühe da gibt's überhaupt keinen
Zweifel dran selbst wenn aljabba mal
sagt no science das stimmt nicht das
wissen alle und ganz am Ende werden sie
Farbe bekennen vielleicht nicht der
riesenurchbruch aber zumindest ein
positives
Signal ich glaube auch wir dürfen die
Kop nicht daran messen was jetzt hier
als großer Durchbruch erwartet wird
sondern wir haben ja auf der einen Seite
die Verhandlungen aber auf der anderen
Seite auch die vielen vielen Begegnungen
und was ich interessant finde ist hier
sitzen Vertreter der
amazonasvölker zusammen mit bänern aus
Europa und debattiert dass solche
Begegnungen stattfinden dass die
deutsche Außenministerin die ja eine
grüne Aktivistin war hier der Ehrengast
der deutschen Industrie ist das ist doch
schon ein Fortschritt den wir gemacht
haben ich glaube das dürfen wir nicht
aus dem Auge verlieren wenn gleich
natürlich die verhandlungsbilanz mit dem
großen Durchbruch sicherlich sehr
traurig sein wird ja aber ich finde
diesen Widerspruch und zwar in seiner
negativen Art Spiel ist liegt ja an
diesem koppräsidenten wir haben da
Bilder vorbereitet hat ja hier die
Eröffnung gemacht der ist ja omnipräsent
er muss das hier zusammenhalten diesen
diesen riesigen konvolut aus fast 200
Staaten er hat gesagt ja es basiert
nicht auf Wissenschaft dass wir raus
müssen aus den fossilen dass wir ohne Öl
Gas und Kohle in die Zukunft müssen er
hat angeblicher das Massiv bestritten ja
gesagt hey diese Deals auch genutzt oder
die vertret die die Konsultation mit den
Regierungen genutzt um Öl und gasdeals
anscheinend voran zu bringen das wirkt
doch irgendwie nach so einem green
wasashing ja ich glaube das ist es auch
ganz klar aber Alja hat auch gesagt
1,5° also der das parisziel der
parispfah ist essential
ja und dann kommt im Nachsatz na aber
wir müssen realistisch sein wir müssen
auch pragmatisch sein nicht glaub das
spiegelt so ein bisschen die ganze Kop
auch wieder wir sitzen vielleicht in in
Deutschland in der EU auf dem relativ
hohen Rost und sagen ha wir müssen
aussteigen in Klammern tun wir ja selber
nicht ja und verlangen von den anderen
richtig voranzugehen die haben ganz
andere Probleme vielleicht nicht
unbedingt die Vereinigten Arabischen
Emirate aber die Länder um die es ja
auch geht die haben ganz andere Probleme
und denen zu sagen schnell sofort hier
so die Fridays for future Forderungen
das können die nicht das werden die
nicht hinkriegen und ich glaube eine
Aufgabe weil du eben auch gesagt hast
die Begegnungen sind wichtig eine
Aufgabe der Kop ist auch die Leute
irgendwie doch noch zusammenzuhalten
zusammenz bringen zu sagen ja wir wissen
um eure Probleme und
lasst uns gemeinsam das irgendwie
hinkriegen und ich glaube das steckt da
irgendwie auch drin in dem was aljaba
gesagt hat der Pragmatismus so doof ich
den finde ja keine Frage ich hät auch
gerne anders was ist denn dein Eindruck
du warst ja jetzt auf vielen
Veranstaltungen hast das jetzt hier
begleitet gibt es denn auch positive
Dinge die bei diesen Begegnungen
rauskommen also ich meine gehen wir
gucken wir mal nicht auf das ganz große
Ziel sondern gibt es etwas wo du sagst h
ja das ist ein step also wenn Du wenn Du
es ansprichst natürlich diese Begegnung
das stimmt schon ja und dass dass man
das Gefühl hat dass vielleicht in der
Wirtschaft viele auch schon weiter sind
dass sie natürlich warten auf die
Signale aber auch erkennen das ist ja
kein Nullsummenspiel was wir hier machen
sondern wir versuchen oder die Welt
versucht die Verluste zu begrenzen die
da kommen und ich glaube kluger Satz war
im Endeffekt dieser Dreischritt okay wir
machen Klimaschutz wir bringen die
Emissionen runter schaffen das nicht
brauchen wir mehr Geld für Schäden die
dann kommen und noch mehr Geld für
Anpassung also wir wir kommen so
negativkreislufen ich glaub viele haben
verstanden dass wir den durchbrechen
müssen nur es muss halt ökonomisch für
jede einzelne Firma sinnvoll sein und
ich glaube da ist halt noch ein großer
GAP und diese transition ich bin
skeptisch weil unsere wir tun uns schon
W und wir sind ja gar nicht abhängig von
Öl Kohle und Gas aber viele Länder hier
sind es Gregor du hast gesagt ne die die
ganz Kleinen die die wenig haben die
wissen überhaupt nicht wie sie das
stellmen die sind so schon überschuldet
und da passiert nichts Klimafinanzierung
die Amerikaner haben 7 Millionen Dollar
in diesen Fond einbezahlt das ist eine
Ohrfeige gewesen ja richtig aber die
Amerikaner haben z.B auch mit dem
Inflation reduction Act 370 Milliarden
keine Ahnung also irsinnig viel Geld
ausgegeben um letztendlich in in
mitigation zu investieren also in in
Klimaschutz ne in Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren jetzt die ganzen Firmen die
jetzt aus Europa abwandern und nach
Amerika gehen die gehen dorthin weil die
Amerikaner irsinnig viel Geld auf den
Tisch gelegt haben ja das ist America
first und es hat nichts mit der
Klimakonferenz zu tun aber es hat was
damit zu tun dass alle kapiert haben
worum es geht und jetzt gucken natürlich
alle dass sie innerhalb ihres
kapitalistischen Denkens ihres
Wirtschaftssystems das beste rausholen
und das mach aber ist es nicht Quark
eigentlich müssen wir noch gucken wo
kann ich mit der Kohle die wir haben
Kohle ist knapp ne Geld ist jetzt nicht
überall Stichpunkt Deutschland ne ist
jetzt nicht überall wirklich massiv auf
dem Tisch dass man die Kohle da
investiert wo sie am meisten Klimaschutz
bringen würde wäre das nicht ein
besserer Ansatz also weil so wird es
sehr national und dann wird's auch sehr
sehr schwierig vor allen Dingen wenn man
dann wieder an die denkt die eben keine
370 Milliarden Dollar haben mal schnell
irgendwo aus dem Haushalt um da zu
investieren
also ich fand es ganz interessant hier
mit den Wissenschaftlern zu reden die ja
hier auch sehr prominent vertreten sind
und auch auf allen Panels ein sehr sehr
düsteres Bild zeichnen über das was
schon geschehen ist wir sind ja schon in
in dem Drama mittendrin also ich meine
wir haben nicht irgendwas hier zu
verhindern sondern wir befinden uns
mittendrin in einer klimatischen Krise
ja und nicht nur in einer klimatischen
sondern das ist im Prinzip ein Krieg der
Menschheit gegen die Erde der enden muss
und die liegen klar auf der Hand und ich
glaube auch die Wahrheit kennt jeder die
Frage ist nur und da sagen die
Wissenschaftler da sind wir jetzt raus
wir haben alles untersucht auf den Tisch
gelegt jetzt ist es eine Frage wer
bezahlt dafür und letztendlich wenn man
sich die Debatten anhört seinen sie auf
nationaler Ebene in Deutschland sein sie
auch auf internationaler Ebene ist es
immer eine Frage letztendlich der
Gerechtigkeit das heißt wer hat die
Schäden verursacht wer zahlt für die
Schäden
und sind wir bereit hier zu
zusammenzustehen und dann guckt euch
doch mal die Debatte in Deutschland an
da Ringen wir darum ob Tempo 130
eingeführt wird dass man das tun sollte
liegt doch klar auf der Hand warum tun
wir das denn nicht und genauso muss man
auch auf globaler Ebene sagen warum
bewegen wir uns denn nicht endlich auf
den Kompromiss und auf die harten
Maßnahmen hin die nötig sind das wissen
alle Länder dass das nötig ist weil wir
um wie viel 16 oder 17 Milliarden Euro
was eine Menge Geld ist gar keine Frage
aber im Vergleich zu dem was wir
an anderer Stelle ausgeben wo
subventioniert wird in Deutschland die
fossile Energiewirtschaft eigentlich in
Klacks und das ist natürlich dann auch
schwer für eine deutsche Position ich
meine die Außenministerin ist
eingetroffen hier hat ja gestern ihren
ersten Auftritt gehabt da haben wir auch
Bilder können wir gucken wie sie hier
einmarschiert ist mit breiter Brust wir
wollen ohne wenn und aber raus aber
natürlich haben andere auch verstanden
ja ja ja ja ja wie läuft das bei euch zu
Hause oh euch ist die Finanzierung des
klimasch Schutz ist um die Ohren
geflogen oh gasdeals macht auch noch aha
registrieren wir Verkehrspolitik
heizungsgesetz nicht dass hier jemand so
tief drin stecken würde aber die Leute
haben natürlich schon Gefühl dafür dass
wir es selbst vielleicht gar nicht
hinkriegen und dann zu fordern ohne
selbst zu liefern nennt man das huchelei
don't know ja so kann man es natürlich
sehen das ist absolut nachvollziehbar
und ich glaube so sehen es auch viele
aber vielleicht muss man auch
so den Blick ein bisschen weiten gestern
ist z.B der klimaschutzindex
veröffentlicht worden und da geht's eben
nicht nur darum was habt ihr geliefert
sondern es geht auch darum was werdet
ihr liefern und ich glaube da seht in
Deutschland doch nicht ganz so düster
aus wir haben immerhin eine grüne Partei
an der Regierung die sich da ich sag mal
bemüht die es vielleicht auch nicht ganz
einfach hat aber die den richtigen Weg
einschlägt und das das kommt ja auch mit
ins Gewicht das ist beim
klimaschutzindex ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt gewesen z.B deshalb ist dort
Indien auf Platz 7 glaube ich weil
Indien sagt okay wir investieren künftig
in ein neu b wir wollen auch ein Stück
weit raus aus der Kohle auch weil sie
natürlich pro Kopf sehr viel weniger
emittieren als Europa das muss man
natürlich auch mit rein reinberechnen
aber so dieses Heuchelei ja
aber der der Weg du hast es eben auch
gesagt der Weg ist uns allen klar und
ich glaube da sind wir im Moment auch ja
weltweit immer noch relativ weit vorne
wir sind z.B in Deutschland was die EU
angeht glaube ich die einzigen die in
diesem grünen Bereich waren auf dem
klimaschutzindex das finde ich immerhin
schon mal beachtlich ja also es ist
nicht alles schlecht wollte ich damit
nur sagen ja aber diese Vorreiterrolle
die wir uns ja gerne zuschreiben als
Deutsche ist auch mein Eindruck haben
wir hier nicht mehr also hier wird eine
ursela von der Lin mit mehr gefeiert als
sagen unsere deutsche Delegation wenn
man mit mit Menschen hier redet die
unterschiedlichen Gruppen der Teilnehmer
und das ist ja schon auch ein
interessanter Punkt ich habe gestern die
Gelegenheit gehabt mit einer Frau zu
reden Namen darf ich nicht nennen weil
das sind natürlich interner die an
diesen Verhandlungen teilnehmt wir als
journalisten dürfen da ja nicht rein es
wäre wahnsinnig interessant würd mich
mal sehr
interessier paar paar Tweets manchal wo
du denkst die reden auch an völlig
aneinander vorbei aber was hat die hat
gesagt da kommen Leute die bringen sich
wirklich Isomatten und Schlafsäcke mit
oder Kissen und die sagt hier z.B die
ganzen Polstermöbel die sind dann heiß
begehrt die debattieren dort die ganze
Nacht und die sagt es wird da teilweise
um ein Wort um einen Satz er bittert
gerungen und dann gibt's auch Streit
dann geht z.B die brasilianische
Delegation raus weil den irgendetwas
nicht gepasst hat also da wird schon das
ist kein Blabla hier wird wirklich
erbittert debattiert und das sehe ich
auch als etwas Positives und sie sagte
das geht genau aber es wird debattiert
ich glaub es wird debattiert und das ich
meine wir leben heute in einer Welt da
reden viele nicht mehr miteinander ich
meine wir haben gesehen Putin und
Lukaschenko sind hier eingeflogen ne
haben sich hier feiern lassen m um im
Prinzip noch mal zu zeigen we don't care
interessiert uns ist das völlig egal und
das ist ja das wo wir gegensteuern und
da sage ich mal hier ist die Welt
vertreten hier ist die Industrie
vertreten hier sind die NGOs vertreten
hier ist die Politik vertreten und zwar
sehr hochrangig und das sehe ich erstmal
schon mal als wenn man sich die Weltlage
insgesamt anguckt als ein sehr positiven
Faktor ja absolut ja ja klar und ich
glaube es geht du hast eben gesagt es
geht um die Milliarden ich glaube es
geht aber auch darum zu verstehen was
die Leute in den Einzel in Ländern für
Probleme haben wenn man z.B sich
Südafrika anguckt ein Viertel des Tages
gibt's ja kein Strom ein Viertel des
Jahres gibt's einfach kein Strom und den
zu sagen ihr müsst eure ganzen
Kohlekraftwerke abschalten hier das ist
doch scheiße ja wir wollen
erneuerbare die haben ganz anderes
Problem China genauso in China die wir
immer Bächen natürlich auch zurecht die
haben auf der einen Seite den höchsten
Zuwachs an Solarenergie wie kein anderes
Land auf der Welt ja die bauen auch so
viele Kohlekraftwerke wie kein anderes
und trotzdem haben die keine
Energiesicherheit auch da haben sie
immer noch ein Problem also wir stehen
an ganz unterschiedlichen Stellen und
deswegen auch wieder Richtung scheitern
also am Anfang hieß es ja das Ziel die
Erneuerbaren Ausbau 2030 verdreifachen
das steht steht jetzt nicht mehr wenn
man so richtig reinhört in die
Verhandler
weil die staten sagen wie wo kommt die
Kohle dafür her unser Energienetz kann
das nicht stemmen wie machen wir das und
insofern war ist dieser ganze positive
Spirit vom Anfang unseres auch nicht
übrigens ne na gut okay aber aber selst
wenn wenn selbst die reichen Länder dann
kann man glaube ich die Position der
ärmeren oder der die eben nicht über
Milliarden verfügen die sie vielleicht
rumschichten können oder auch eben nicht
aber die da gar nicht drüber diskutieren
können dass die dann sagen ne kriegen
wir nicht hin und das ist schon krass
weil da war echt viel Optimismus so die
ersten zwei Tage dachte man wow da da da
geht jetzt was und am Ende wird
gestritten um diesen einen Punkt ne
kriegen wir den Ausstieg aus dem
fossilen Zeitalter hin machen wir das
irgendwie mit zwei drei formulier
aber da die Kurve jetzt echt bisschen
abgesoffen und sehr viel mehr
Pessimismus vielleicht gehört das zu so
einer Kop ja weil es natürlich auch so
schwierig ist aber ich weiß nicht war
das ist das immer so das am Schluss sag
mitterm Blues ne bei den Kops das ist
wohl tatsächlich immer so also auf den
auf den ich war war das tatsächlich auch
immer so deshalb kommen ja dann auch die
Minister ne das wird wie be bei der
Ausschussarbeit im Bundestag ne vorher
wird was vorbereitet sag mal von den
niedereren Rängen ja und dann gibt ganz
viele eckige also viele verschiedene
Optionen und D heißt so ihr werdet dafür
bezahlt ihr habt das leer jetzt streitet
euch drum genau das passiert jetzt auch
heißt natürlich noch lange nicht dass
hinterher gut geht ne also kann kann
dann z.B Annalena bärbock die ja jetzt
hier wie du schon sagtest breitschüldrig
eingeflogen ist etwas erreichen hängt
das auch an an an Personen ja absolut
also ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig was
auch für für Netzwerke vorher natürlich
geschlossen werden ann ber ist z.B für
mit also für Klimaschutz ist sie eine
der
hauptverhandlerin da wird die natürlich
alles ins Zeug legen sich ins Zeug legen
das glaube ich schon ja und dieses du
hast es ja vorhin angesprochen diese
persönlichen diese persönlich
Begegnungen ja das ist bei den
Verhandlern ja auch nicht anders sind ja
auch Menschen also da hast du auch einen
dem vertraust du mehr einen vertraust du
weniger einen hast du das ganze Jahr
lang über begleitet und sagst okay komm
und dort jetzt versuchen was ir
gemeinsam hinzukriegen das ist ja
genauso aber da war auch ich meine das
hat glaube ich auch viele ein bisschen
gestört dass das so groß geworden ist
jetzt hier ne dass hier über 100.000
registriert waren das verteilt sich
natürlich auch hier auf diesem riesigen
Gelände ähm wir hatten die Staats- und
Regierungschefs hier am Anfang haben wir
auch ein paar Bilder können wir mal
reingucken wie die sich hier präsentiert
haben musste das denn sein wenn jetzt am
Ende ja die Außenministerin oder bei
vielen ist die Umweltministerin oder ich
mE eben die die designiert sind in den
Ländern ist denn so ein Aufriss dann
nötig das bringt bringt das was nach
vorne oder ist das einfach so ein
Schaulaufen der Stars sage ich mal am
Anfang und eigentlich so ein
bisschen ja es ist einfach zu groß und
zu viel geworden kann man das nicht
bisschen kleiner dampfen weil im
Endeffekt spielt ja in den kleinen
Räumen in den plenarselen ja aber es ist
ja wahnsinnig Komplex es geht hier um
wirklich um unglaublich komplexe Details
ja ich habe mich no mit dem flasbart
unterhalten Jochen flasbart
Staatssekretär im früher im
Bundesumweltministerium jetzt im
Entwicklungsministerium der wirklich
seit ich glaube seit seit 15 Cops dabei
ist der ist super drin und er sagt diese
ganzen detailverhandlung über technische
Einzelheiten und sowas da habe ich keine
Ahnung da haben die ihren Stab für und
das in jedem einzelnen Segment das sind
ja hier hunderte also von daher glaube
ich schon dass zumindest auf Seiten der
der Delegationen dieser Aufriss an
Menschen absolut gerechtfertigt ist
einfach weil die Materie so kompliziert
ist ne ob jetzt dann wirklich 246 Öl und
gaslobbyisten hier sein müssen okay aber
das ist das ist vielleicht auch ein
Ausdruck dass die ihre Fälle
wegschwimmen sehen ich meine auf eine
Konferenz wo wo nichts me rauskommt gut
die kann ich verzichten was ist das Ziel
der Kop gucken wir mal einfach drauf
ja und dann ist doch die Tatsache dass
so viele hier in Schaulauf betreiben
sagt doch dass die Agenda wichtig
genommen wird die Agenda wird sogar so
wichtig genommen dass ein Putin sich
bemüßigt fühlt hier mal zu zeigen dass
er sie nicht wichtig nimmt und wir
können jetzt natürlich immer auf die
negativen Aspekte gucken und das müssen
wir auch aber ich versuche jetzt mal den
Blick auf die positiven zu lenken dann
ist die Tatsache dass die ganze Welt
hier vertreten ist und auch hochrangige
Regierungsvertreter von Staaten die das
nicht unbedingt ganz vorne auf der
Agenda haben dass die hier präsent sind
dass die Ringen darum dass die
debattieren darum das finde ich ist
schon ein großer Schritt der kommt viel
zu spät und alles geht viel zu langsam
wenn man sich anguckt was wir eigentlich
erreichen müssen aber dennoch was ist
die Alternative es gibt keine
Alternative dazu sich zu treffen zu
debattieren und ich find es ehrlich
gesagt ein bisschen kleinlich wenn wir
jetzt anfangen un zählen irgendwie wir
sind jetzt hier 70.000 100.000 wie groß
sind die Delegationen ja also ich habe
hier auf der Kop niemanden getroffen der
in den wunderschönen Hotels in denen wir
hier sind am Swimmingpool sitzt die
Swimmingpools sind ausgestorben und die
Leute arbeiten hier wirklich also die
sind hier nicht zum Spaß ich war einmal
morgens schwimmen ich geb's zu
ja ich meine das hat natürlich den
glitzerfaktor hier aber was mich also
was mich beeindruckt hat positiv ist
Kolumbien wir waren kaum hatten wir
unsere zellti hier aufgeschlagen kam
jemand von der kolumbischen
columbianischen Delegation und sofort
WhatsApp vernetzen und die haben es hier
ganz groß vor und ich war jetzt
Kolumbien war jetzt nicht mein mein
Fachgebiet und habe ich da mal
reingeguckt und die sind extrem
progressiv obwohl sie von Kohle abhängen
also die sagen wir schneiden uns lieber
da ins eigene Fleisch aber wir müssen
diesen turn schaffen und das zeigt dass
es natürlich auch im globalen Süden wier
hier ja immer wieder genannt wird in den
Entwicklungsländern
teilweise Spirit gibt aber ich glaube
wenn du sagst wir haben nicht genug wir
haben vielleicht mit dem Geld das nicht
so wichtig aber ich glaube die hätten so
ein bisschen mehr Incentive ein bisschen
mehr Anreiz dass man denen sagt okay wir
nehmen euch mit wir brechen euch auch
raus aus dieser veralance von China
Saudi-Arabien Iran und so die die
Blockierer das hätte geholfen ich glaube
da hat man hat man es ein bisschen
versemmelt wenn man da bisschen mehr
hingelegt hätte an Geld an Willen ja ich
meine dass das mit dem Geld schwierig
ist wenn da Millionen 400 500 Milliarden
und wo soll das herkommen aber wenn man
ein bisschen mehr Willen gezeigt hätte
hätte man die vielleicht rausbrechen
können und dann noch mehr Druck erzeugen
eben auf die Blockierer sagen hey die
Welt will raus ihr jetzt wirklich
nicht ich glaube das hätte vielleicht
geholfen ich Vib da hat
Europa Amerika also die die reichen
Länder haben vielleicht eine Chance
verpasst da mm du hast ja auch Einblick
so ein bisschen ins Finanzsystem sage
ich mal ganz vorsichtig
mein Eindruck ist
eben gesagt das letzte Aufflackern der
Öl und Gasindustrie dass tatsächlich die
die Trillionen um die es ja letztendlich
an Geld geht in den nächsten 20 30 40 50
Jahren dass die langsam beginnen sich zu
bewegen das nicht mehr in
in die alten fossilen im großen Stil
zumindest in unserem europäischen
Bereich investiert wird wen man sagt das
sind stranded Assets damit kann ich
überhaupt kein Geld mehr verdienen auf
lange Sicht siehst du das auch so das
sehe ich auch so und ich glaube also
wenn man sich so unterhält mit den
Delegationen die z.B hier sind die die
Finanzindustrie vertreten die sind ja
auch engagiert in in in tollen Projekten
teilweise
dann kommt natürlich der Push auch von
den Kunden also was ich so höre sind die
Kunden heute nicht mehr die gleichen wie
noch sag mal die Generation der heutigen
er die wollen nicht unbedingt in
schädliche Industrien investieren und
sagen ja also wir müssen doch in die
Zukunft investieren letztendlich hängt
auch unglaublich viel von uns
Verbrauchern ab ich wundere mich z.B
hier ich war hier auf sehr sehr vielen
Veranstaltungen Empfängen und so weiter
unzählich kann ich gar nicht mehr
nachrechnen auf einem einzigen gab es
vegetarisches Essen einem einzigen wir
sind ja auf der Kop sorry aber ich meine
wenn wir reden immer davon uns zu
bewegen auch das ich glaube es reicht
nicht allein den Blick auf
Vereinbarungen zu lenken sondern auch
wenn die Zeit drängt müssen wir auch den
Blick auf unser Wertesystem lenken und
da glaube ich hat die Kop schon so ein
paar gute Impulse gesetzt z.B dass das
Thema Biodiversität dass die
Frage ist die gesamte Welt für den
Schutz z.B eines Regenwaldes wie wir in
den Brasilien haben zuständig das sind
doch auch Fragen die etwas mit unserem
Wert zu tun haben ja stellt die Natur an
sich einen Wert da welchen Respekt haben
wir gegenüber der
Natur nicht immer nur auf Zahlen und
Daten gucken sondern auch mal auf solche
Fakten was wertschätzen wir oder und
Lust ja und lustigerweise ist das ja
auch ein Geschäftsmodell also bei allem
bei allem wohlmeinenden Humanismus ja es
ist auch ein Geschäftsmodell blue Caron
z.B nennt sich das die verereinigten
Arabischen Emirate haben massiv
investiert z.B in Simbabwe und in
anderen Ländern in Afrika um zu sagen
okay dieses Land das gehört sozusagen
CO2 technisch gerechnet uns und wir
investieren hier Millionen Milliarden in
diese blue carpen Geschichten weil wir
glauben das wird zukünftig ein ein
lukratives Geschäft sein ja aber
natürlich sehr viel Kritik da auch und
also die Zivilgesellschaft die hier
überhaupt keine Rolle spielt also ich
hatte mir eine Kop das ist meine erste
richtige Kop so vorgestellt dass hier
Demonstrationszüge dieser sehr gut
organisierten vernetzten
internationalen Organisationen wie
Fridays for future und und und in jedem
Land gibt's das ja in unterschiedlichen
Ausprägung dass die hier
durchmarschieren wir haben paar Bilder
da auch das ist ein bisschen peinlich
muss man es nennen wenn die da auf so
einem ja 10 x 10 Square da irgendwie
ihre und man hat so bisschen das Gefühl
ist echt sehr
gewollt na ja wir sehen halt hier
schon in welchem Land diese Kopf
stattfindet also
es finden keine Demos statt auf den
Gebieten die von diesem Staat
kontrolliert werden fehlt das ja
natürlich natürlich ich meine wenn wir
sagen wichtig an der Kop ist der
Meinungsaustausch dann dürfen wir den
auch nicht verhindern und natürlich gibt
es auch die Gruppen die hier
protestieren und die auch einen guten
Grund haben zu protestieren das ist ja
auch finde ich Teil der Kreativität die
nötig ist um weiter
umzudenken und ich find schon teilweise
sehr beängstigend also man kann hier z.B
WhatsApp Telefonate nicht führen weil
das Netz irgendwie
[Musik]
kontrolliert wird man kann nur
Textmessages senden also das fine ich
jetzt schon manchmal ein bisschen
beklemmend auch wenn man sich umguckt
überall
Kameras also ich habe auch so bei den
bei den NGOs bei den Aktivisten so das
Gefühl die müssen sich inzwischen auch
vor ihrer eigenen Community
rechtfertigen ob der ganze Aufwand der
natürlich damit verbunden ist auf Kop zu
reisen ja mit einer großen Delegation
sozusagen ob der noch gerechtfertigt ist
bei den mageren Ergebnissen die be
rumkommen für aus deren Sicht aus deren
sichten sich Luisa Neubau hat es gestern
gesagt die sagte noch glauben wir dran
an diesen Prozess der Klimakonferenzen
aber der Druck wird auch bei denen stim
aber wir waren beide bei als sie da
gesprochen hat auch mit mit Christoph
bals von German watch der glaube ich
wenn man gefühlt die Kop mit erfunden
hat
absolut J auf 29 Kop war der W 28 gab
weil Rio schon oder beim es gab ein
Vorbereitung ir Sondertreffen oder
irgendwas aber aber da das fand ich
spannend dass sag ja auch in Deutschland
gibt's backlash also da geht's wieder
zurück dass man da das die
Versammlungsfreiheit also das war das
hatte ich wirkich das ging mir total
gegen Strich mich auch gewundert war das
war das hart also ich fand es ein
bisschen hart dass wir Gefühl haben in
Deutschland können wir es gibt ein
bisschen K wir haben die klimakleber das
ist ein hochsensibles Ding ja keine
Frage ne Protest muss der weh tun darf
der weh tun ja wenn man morgens im Stau
steht aber man hat das Gefühl dass ist
klar es gibt so einen Meinungsumschwung
aber dass das sich auch ausdrückt dass
die sich irgendwie das fand ich schon
erstaunlich oder habe ich echt gezuckt
so ein bisschen ich kann das jetzt
schlecht beurteilen ich weiß nicht ist
das sind wir da auch auf dem auf dem
Rückschritt hoffentlich nicht ja
also nur noch kurz weil weil wir die
Cops auch angesprochen hatten also das
ist natlich bei der letzten Cop in
Ägypten schon schwierig gewesen es ist
jetzt glaube ich nicht ganz einfach es
laufen hier viele Jungs rum mit äh
Handys die dich fotografieren die ganz
nah rangehen um dein Gesicht auch
wirklich abzufotografieren
äh wir haben alle unsere biometrischen
Daten beim Eingang in dieses Land
hinterlassen also das heißt noch lange
nicht dass jetzt etwas passiert aber es
ist zumindest ein gewisses druckgebäude
das so aufgebaut wird ne und ähm das das
ist schon hart und die Proteste von den
von den Aktivisten sind hier natürlich
begrenzt wenn die hier mit einer kleinen
Delegation kommen dann ist das nicht
weil die äh weil die sagen ach das ist
wir halten das nicht für wichtig oder
sowas sondern weil die auch ihre Leute
schützen müssen das war in Ägypten so
dass viele Aktivisten aus Afrika nicht
gekommen sind weil sie gesagt haben wenn
wir in Ägypten protestieren dann werden
wir in unserem eigenen Land später
werden wir dafür im schlimmsten Fall da
gibt's eine zwei klassenesellschaft ne
es gibt die die Aktivisten AktivistInnen
aus den westlichen Ländern die haben
einfacher na klar und dann gibt es und
das das fand ich krass dass sie das so
offen sagen und und wenn du jetzt aus
dem globalen Süden kommst ja wo
natürlich auch die Repression in deinem
eigenen Land ja wo ja auch Austausch
stattfindet teilweise das finde ich
krass dass die also sagen da gibt's eine
Zweiklassengesellschaft absolut ich
glaube das ist ein sehr wichtiger Punkt
wir sprechen ja immer so generell von
dem globalen Süden und was der globale
Süden gerne hätte aber auch im globalen
Süden gibt es Eliten und gibt es die
Masse und auch da ist es letztendlich
eine Frage der Gerechtigkeit und ich
sage mal so die
Länder die hier mit dem Argument kommen
wir können das nicht stemmen weil das
akzeptieren die armen Menschen in
unserem Land nicht reden doch immer erst
einmal für ihre eigenen Eliten wenn man
sich mal die Zahlen genau anguckt ja
also wenn es um solche Debatten geht wie
darf man Wasser verteuern darf man Strom
verteuern für wen verteuert man es denn
letztendlich ja also da gibt's ganz
interessante Zahlen dass z.B in
bestimmten Städten in inden das Wasser
zu 97% von wohlhabenden Leuten
verbraucht wird und nur 3% von den Armen
und wenn ich dann darüber rede dass das
Wasser nicht teurer gemacht werden darf
ist das eine absurde Diskussion sondern
im Prinzip wäre es gerechter die armen
3% dann zu unterstützen dass sie sich
das Wasser leisten können und deswegen
letztendlich sind das immer Debatten um
den gerechten Ausgleich und ich glaube
die Welt einfach so einzuteilen globaler
Süden globaler Norden funktioniert nicht
mehr es funktioniert auch das Bild
Entwicklungsland
gegen entwickeltes Land nicht mehr also
da muss man schon in die Details auch
reingucken das ist wichtig ja das ist ja
eine Einteilung hier die kommt noch von
1992 ne also das ist nun da war die Welt
wirklich eine andere und deshalb nennt
sich ja China auch immer noch
Schwellenland auf der anderen Seite muss
man nich auch sagen es gibt Gegenden in
China das ist wirklich Entwicklungsstand
ne
und also ich glaube wir brauchen neue
Einteilung ich glaube wir brauchen auch
diese dieses schwarz-weiß globaler Süden
globaler Norden das das funktioniert so
nicht mehr aber auch da ist die Kop
glaube ich die einzige Chance um genau
sowas noch mal neu zu sortieren man
hat's ja versucht aufzubrechen diese
Anfang als Deutschland und die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate sich
hinstellen sagen so wir machen jetzt
diesen Fond für Schäden und Verluste
zahlen da erstmal ein der Set setzen wir
den jetzt auf machen den sozusagen
bereit und das war zum ersten Mal dass
ein noch als Entwicklungsland F das Land
nämlich eben die Emirate da irgendwie
einbezahlt haben dann hat man gehofft
jetzt müssen auch Saudi-Arabien China
vor allem in
Ölland alle die die Amerikaner müssen
alle Mal aus der Deckung kommen und
sagen so jetzt müssen wir mal mehr da
reingeben und das hat bis jetzt auch
nicht funktioniert leider ich meine
vielleicht dauert das länger vielleicht
ist ein Prozess aber das war so eine
kleine Enttäuschung weil ich GLB das war
schon die Hoffnung dass man so ein
Kickstart macht und dann packen halt mal
ein paar Länder die es sich leisten
können die Schwellenländer
Entwicklungsländer sind wo man denkt das
prokopfon kommen bei euch ist höher als
bei uns wie kann das sein aber aber das
hat nicht funktioniert das aber die
Tatsache dass es überhaupt gemacht haben
ich meine das da wurde ja erbittert
drüber über Jahre auch gestritten das he
ja sie erkennen es an dass es
Verursacher von Schäden gibt und dass es
Opfer von Schäden gibt das ist schon mal
finde ich ein ganz kleiner Schritt und
wie gesagt es geht nicht schnell genug
und das Geld reicht auch nicht und die
betroffenen Länder die ja von aus diesem
Fond Nutzen ziehen sollen kritisieren ja
auch das was sind denn die Kriterien
dass wir Geld daraus bekommen wie lange
wird denn das dauern bis wir das Geld
zur Verfügung haben aber ich finde
dieser step zu klar zumachen hier gibt
es Täter und Opfer schon mal gut und
dass es ein Ausgleich geben muss ja
Finale Statement ist diese Kop top oder
flop Fang du an
[Gelächter]
Katrin oder wie immer ist alles grau dar
darf ich auch etwas in der Mitte sagen
natlich für mich ist sie für mich ist
sie wahrscheinlich Flop wenn es um den
großen Durchbruch geht den erwarte ich
nicht von dieser Kop eindeutig Flop Top
ist sie für mich was die
Vernetzung der Welt angeht wenn es um
das Thema geht wie können wir die Erde
retten und im Prinzip unsere Zukunft
garantieren da sind wir glaube ich auf
dieser Kop auf dem richtigen Weg also da
top ich mich anschließen also ich glaube
auch das kommt nicht der große
Durchbruch da bin ich glaube ich dann
doch Pessimist genug aber das Drumrum
hier das ist wirklich immer größer
geworden und ich glaube das Drumrum wird
wichtiger als die eigentliche politische
Kop be drumrum noch eine nette Botschaft
wir haben ein paar Bilder von einer von
einer Party die hier von so einem
Karnevalsumzug aller Dubai würde ich es
mal nennen vielleicht können wir das
noch mal uns angucken m also man hat
zumindest versucht für gute Stimmung zu
sorgen also man hat sich Mühe gegeben
und das mag jetzt ein bisschen nach ne
Kölsche Karneval Aussehen nee aber das
ist es hier kommt die Welt zusammen
genau es ist Bund es ist sind alle da ja
und ich mein deswegen ich
sagen es ist ein Flop mit
Potenzial es geht in die richtige
Richtung die Welt blickt in die richtige
Richtung ich war überrascht dass also
das das Business und dass die die die im
Endeffekt das ja stemmen müssen denn es
kann ja nicht aus öffentlichen Geldern
finanziert werden ich meine diese Summen
das Business ist es und dass die weiter
sind
und ob das reicht um wirklich die Folgen
die ja exponentiell gravierender werden
die wir in diesem Jahr gesehen haben das
war ein
Ausnahmejahr klar noch ein Ausnahmejahr
aber das wird das neue normal und dann
gehen wir ja noch weiter und wenn das
ist das was einen Sorge macht aber
vielleicht liegt es einfach in jetzt W
nicht philosophisch werden aber in Natur
uns von uns Menschen dass wir erst
richtig Notbremse machen können wenn es
wirklich ich weh tut bei Corona ging es
auch ja ja vielleicht auch sehr
umstritten aber wir haben in viele
Länder innerhalb von Wochen Monaten
Dinge möglich gemacht auch finanziell
die undenkbar schienen das hät man vor
einem Jahr oder ein Jahr davor jemand
gefragt gesagt aber jetzt guck dir mal
an wir müssten jedes Jahr ein einen
Rückgang an CO2 haben wie in der
coronazeit wo die Industrie quasi
Stillstand fast jedes Jahr um 7% um noch
diese 43 bis 2030 hinzukriegen eng wir
eng ja
ich glaube jetzt können Sie vielleicht
besser entscheiden für sich selbst danke
dass Sie zugeschaut haben zugehört haben
wir werden gehen jetzt hier auf die
Zielgrade werden das weiter verfolgen es
beginnen jetzt die langen Poker Nächte
und Tage in Dubai mit vielen Augenringen
das geht jetzt langsam los und dann
haben wir vielleicht am Dienstag am
Mittwoch am Donnerstag oder am Freitag
wer weiß das schon diese Cops gehen
gerne in die Verlängerung ein Ergebnis
bis dahin
ciao
[Musik]